das ist das ich bin so gespannt was
jetzt passiert was muss ich tun Fragen
ziehen die roten sind unverschämte
Fragen die Grünen sind harmlose Fragen
okay ich halte mir die Option auf den
Fragen kurz an aber nicht zu beantworten
richtig
aber hat ich fange aber schon an zu
lesen hat ihn schon mal jemand auf den
Kopf gespuckt
nicht mit Absicht
höchstens im Sinne von wir reden
miteinander und dabei wird automatisch
Speichel freigegeben ich lasse mich ja
gerne provozieren
und machen das alle
echt dann nehme ich jetzt gleich die
Grünen ich will ja nicht so sein die
alle anderen geht es ihnen auf die
Nerven dazu
hat ich hatte ja gerne zurück außerdem
fruchtbare Böden wollen beackert werden
so ich nehme jetzt die sind ganz harmlos
die sind echt ganz anders
was ist 2 + 2 sind sie auch privat immer
so lustig nein
wie ist das dann ich bin nein ich finde
nein ich bin ein sehr positiv denkender
Mensch und es ist relativ schwierig mich
ein schlechte Laune zu versetzen aber
ich habe natürlich auch wie sich das für
ein Menschen gehört auch ernsthafte
Seiten und ja zeige vor allen Dingen die
andere im Fernsehen
sie sind so schlagfertig kann man das
lernen oder ist das ein Talent tja also
ich persönlich hänge ja der Theorie an
dass es nicht Talente gibt sondern das
möchte ein Tier zu etwas ist und das ist
eine Frage der Motivation ist also ein
Sportler ist ich dann besonders gut weil
er ein besonderes Talent hat sondern
weil er besonders motiviert wurde als es
gelernt hatte bestes Beispiel auch hier
können wir dir die Statistik bemühen
sind Fußballer besonders gute Fußballer
müssten ja theoretisch gehäuft im Januar
auf die Vergleich verteilt über die Welt
im Jahr auf die Welt kommen weil das
Talent sich ja nicht in einem Monat
kumulieren sollte warum auch man stellt
aber fest dass die talentierten Fußball
alle am Anfang des Jahres geboren wurde
oder nicht alle aber gehäuft und das
hängt einfach damit zusammen dass in
Fußballverein sind die Leute nach
Jahrgängen sortiert und die ältesten
sind einfach immer die besten hätten
einfach sehr viel mehr und sehr viel
früher Motivation
Belohnungen blablabla so und das ist so
ein Effekt und deshalb glaube ich dass
ich einfach sehr oft bei spontan
Reaktionen eine positive Resonanz
bekommen habe so dass ich mich getraut
habe ich mache schon mal weiter so dass
mich getraut habe einfach in der Art
einfach dann weiterzumachen so was ist
das Geheimnis ihres Erfolges das weiß
ich nicht das wird wahrscheinlich
irgendwann mal ein
Theaterwissenschaftler im Jahre 2068
schreiben über wenn er dazu sagt noch
immer treten Künstler im Stile bei
natureckers auf deutschen Bühnen auf der
wird dann sagen was sie sich bei diesem
Spiel handelt aber das ist rot gewesen
wenn man nicht dem schöner als ideale
entspricht muss man dann lustig sein um
eine Frau abzukriegen ja diese Frage
betrifft mich ja überhaupt nicht keine
Ahnung ich glaube das letzten Endes ich
hänge ich sage immer Theorien Anhänger
das sind so Ideen die ich habe die aber
auch wieder falsch sein können ich
glaube Menschen
gehören einer bestimmten
schönheitskategorie an dann haben einen
bestimmten Wert und die Leute passen
meistens also meistens zum schönen
schöner als ideal in sind in derselben
Kategorie und Liebeskummer entsteht
daraus dass man sich selber falsch
einschätzen also man denkt ich bin der
Adonis aber
adonisator oder wie die Frauen heißen
interessieren sich nicht für einen weil
das weil es einfach nicht passt und dann
hat mein Liebeskummer und irgendwann
schafft man es also ein Ungleichheit
indem man entweder dann halt vielleicht
witzig ist oder viel Geld hat oder
Karriere gemacht hat oder irgendetwas
sie haben schon so viele Preise für ihn
bekommen welcher fehlt ihnen noch naja
den grippepreis hätten wir dieses Jahr
fast gekriegt aber den hat er dann doch
Weihnachten bekommen diese
Weihnachtssendung auch eine Parodie
Sendung sehr lustig ich habe echt sehr
viel gelacht und ähm ansonsten
freue ich mich über jeden Preis immer
eine Form der sind einfach
Auszeichnungen und warum soll ich nicht
hingehen und ich darüber freuen brauchen
Sie für Metal Musik und Ballerspiele am
Computer um unterschiedliche
Aggressionen abzubauen
und sage auch jetzt wieder öffentlich
ich bin dafür dass er sehr ab 18 sein
soll das soll auch Frauen auf den
Spielen drauf stehen damit die und auch
unten rechts in den man sollte in den
Spielen ist immer einblenden damit
Eltern die versehen nicht mal
vorbeikommen sehen die Kinder spielen
etwas was wofür sie noch zu jung sind
ob ich das brauche weiß ich nicht ich
weiß noch nicht mal ob ich damit
Aggression überhaupt abbaue es macht
einfach Spaß und ich meine nicht viel
Aggression zu haben also ich baue glaube
ich beim Musik mehr Aggressionen ab als
sport ist gut um Aggression abzubauen
weniger
wenn man dann da steht und dann laufen
die Tränen übers Gesicht weil weil
einfach eine wunderschöne Ballade
gespielt wird und dann kommt irgendwie
so ein anderer Limette Fan der gerade
nicht damit umgehen kann dass sein
Körper von Emotionen über über Wald wird
und sagt ich könnte ja so im Fernsehen
ne dann stört das leider so ein bisschen
deshalb bin ich nicht so oft da aber ich
höre es im Auto sehr gerne sehr laut
stimmt es dass sie so ein kollegialer
Kollege sind das weiß ich gar nicht ich
persönlich kenne keine Kollegen mit
denen ich mich wirklich also der
Kollegenkreis es gibt keine Leute die
man wirklich nicht mag es ist so ein
bisschen die Schule oder wie eine
Familie da sind Leute bei wo man denkt
boah
die sind auch da und wo man den Humor
nicht so teilt der was aber okay ist und
es gibt Leute da freut man sich total
drauf aber das ist sich für sie wäre mir
glaube ich zu anstrengend mich mit
anderen Leuten zu stressen wir hatten
die Frage wer hat das denn wer hat denn
die Aussage gemacht dass man daraus eine
Frage formulieren konnte das
interessiert sie werden besonders
Kollege es gibt ja andere Leute die
nicht so kollegial sind also wo da mal
einer rausfliegt vom Set oder so weil
der einfach also ich glaube das liegt
auch da ich will immer dass mich alle
lieb haben
sie ihr Buch wirklich selbst geschrieben
diese Frage warum ist die rot
ist schon im Hals ist das nicht
unverschämt nein es gibt viele die ihre
Bücher nicht selber schreiben aber ich
habe mein Buch komplett selber
geschrieben ich hatte natürlich eine
Lektorin die mir geholfen hat und bei
der anderen Recherchearbeit habe ich
dann jemanden gehabt wo der Mann Sachen
aber ich habe Prinzip alles selber
geschrieben und es gibt sogar Leute die
sagen und das merkt man leider
das ist halt der Nachteil es ist ich man
wenn ich das lese und jetzt selber auch
denke ich also ja gut das ein paar
Sachen das machen das andere so aber ich
hatte total Spaß beim Lesen beim
schreiben und schreiben das macht total
Spaß macht richtig was gemacht haben und
finde es ich wollte auch angeboten es
gibt auch ein Buch angeboten
wir schreiben doch das Buch es geht um
den Namen und natürlich die Ideen dass
ich nicht wenn ich ein Buch schreibe
wenn ich das auch selber machen und habe
auch lange nach dem Thema gesucht wo man
was zu schreiben kann wo ich was zu
schreiben kann
warum sucht man da so lang ja worüber
soll man schreiben also in mein
Lebenswerk zu schreiben ist jetzt ein
bisschen
weiß ich nicht dann kann man natürlich
viele private Schicksale beschreiben
aber das ist privat das will ich nicht
schreiben also was gibt es noch eine
Geschichte weil sie nicht eine
Geschichte weiß ich nicht und sofern ist
halt ganz gut dass man einfach über
etwas schreibt was sich so
was ich selber mache
wunderbar es klingelt ich vermute das
ist der Fahrer der mich dazu genial
daneben fährt
zur Arbeit manchmal gefahren werden
ja dann gute Fahrt ja vielen Dank sehr
viel Spaß gemacht